foreign
card keep your head down your work will
speak for itself
this was my mom's advice for a lot of
things uh School Hobbies life in general
and it hit a little bit differently
because I knew that it was coming from
her position as an immigrant mom in a
foreign country and culture
but that said
let's take a show of hands how many of
you have heard this advice or something
similar to it before
all right decent number
how many of you actually believe it
there we go
come in late
well I believed it uh as a new grad out
of college as a software engineer I was
going into my first job and I was a ball
of nerves I was so anxious so I
basically clung to this advice like a
lifeline
gotta keep my head down gotta work hard
don't make waves hustle that's it that's
it and all that anxiety kept bubbling up
through way too many HR onboarding
meetings until finally I was able to sit
down at my ergonomic Herman Miller chair
you pull out my brand new Macbook Pro
and get to work
it's kind of hard to let your work speak
for yourself
when you have no idea what you're
supposed to be working on
first day huh
want me to show you the ropes
that was OJ
imagine me except slightly shorter and
with perfectly quaffed here
or just hair I suppose
he was also a new grad but he had been
around at the company for about nine
months longer than I did and any time I
had a question I was able to come to him
and immediately the anxiety would drain
away
how do I get rebase What spark where can
I buy a sandwich all important questions
that I need answered on my first day
but I had a friend I had a colleague I
had a comrade and rather than clinging
to that advice as a lifeline
all
I was comfortable and I was able to get
done
so after one very long night of
debugging memory issues when basically
we went out for drinks
he let slip how much he was making
and I felt a pit grow in my stomach
that was less than me
that was noticeably less than me
we were doing the same work at the same
place
had the same experience except for that
part where you know he trained me
and I was making more than him
this isn't an anomaly
for a lot of immigrant workers living
with a sword of Visa sponsorship over
their head
there aren't that many options and
without options it's much more difficult
to negotiate and if you can't negotiate
work very easily becomes a one-sided
bargain
and it's not just immigrant workers
the systemic and illegal underpayment of
workers is known as wage theft
and it happens to construction
subcontractors to farm hands to
high-skilled Immigrant laborers and to
service workers but most in general it
happens to people who have very few
options like Ajay
but not me
because I had citizenship through no
fault of my own because my dad was the
one who moved to the U.S
for my dad's first job out of college he
was also an engineer he was working at a
manufacturing plant in Kuwait even
though he graduated from India
and as an Indian worker he got paid
one-third the amount of people doing the
exact same work
three miles down the road
so it's not surprising that some a
number of his co-workers ended up
striking looking for better wages and
working conditions it's also not
surprising that management didn't
immediately give them higher wages
but they didn't even try to negotiate
they didn't even acknowledge there was a
problem the first thing they did was to
ask my dad and other Engineers to take
up guns to protect the factory machinery
basically taking up arms against their
colleagues who just wanted better
working conditions
now in my dad's case the answer was
obvious hell no
and at the first opportunity
he decided to leave to immigrate to the
U.S where hopefully he could find a
better system
but in the U.S
wage theft is the largest form of
property theft it dwarfs all others
combined armed robbery larceny Grand
Theft Auto put them all together you
don't even come close
50 billion dollars a year
that's 50 with a 5-0 that's around the
same size as the GDP of Wyoming
people who are illegally paid under
minimum wage
15 billion dollars
it happens to people who have few
options
and it happens only a few dollars at a
time
which is why it's so pervasive
now you might be feeling the same way I
did
which is to say that you might be
feeling frustrated and you might be
feeling powerless you might be feeling
angry and shocked at the scale of what's
what's occurring
but you also might be wondering to
yourself
there's not that much that I can do
wrong
I believe that we're actually at an
inflection point here
for the first time public support of
workers protections and unions more
broadly has crossed 70 percent in the
U.S
in the post-covet era now that we
finally have tight labor markets you
actually see workers blue and white
collar in a position to negotiate for
however briefly work is actually a
two-sided bargain again
and in this moment we have an
opportunity
now it's become fashionable with a lot
of Technologies like chat gbt and other
automation to talk about the future of
work to worry about okay are people is
this going to make work transactional
and are workers going to be replaceable
but I hope I've convinced you by now
that that's actually been the case for
decades
a more productive conversation
is how can we use technology to improve
the future of workers and by that I mean
unlike my dad at his first job and me at
mine how can we ensure that our
children's first experience in the
workplace isn't as a one-sided bargain
bye
and we do have the ability to build
technologies that actually do restore
balance to the workplace and protect
workers rights
Communications Technologies so that way
workers can organize and also raise
complaints
user interfaces that can make sense of
complex financial information so that
way when you get your paycheck you
actually know if you're getting what
you're owed
Analytics
so that way you can identify and call
out bad behavior
all of these are tools and processes
that we can Institute in the
organizations that we intend to enter or
start
work hard
keep your head down and your work will
speak for itself
part of the reason we all hear this
advice is because we want to believe
that work will actually pays and that
good work gets rewarded we want to
believe that work is a two-sided bargain
and the people in this room have the
ability to make that happen
because in the organizations that we go
on to enter that we go on to lead that
we go on to do business with we can
actually Institute these cultural
changes to make sure that work remains
this two-sided bargain with tools and
processes to ensure a balanced workplace
and for me
that's what really matters because
that's how we Define the future of
workers not just for us entering into
the environment now but for coming
Generations thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]